Andres is God a hedonist I would say so
yes I mean all of the evidence indicates
that pretty much every animal with a
nervous system on this planet has a
pleasure pain axis it's fascinating to
see even tiny creatures like flatworms
retiree grades in a sense response to
recreational drugs like alcohol and
opioids and amphetamines and you can
actually see they cause the
reinforcement signal and and they wiggle
differently under those conditions
recently it was found out that octopodes
actually respond to MDMA in a way that
is pretty similar to humans they become
more cuddly in some sense the reward
circuitry the pleasure pain axis seems
to be kind of a unifying motivational
system across the animal kingdom and
maybe God is not optimizing for ultimate
pleasure and happiness because the
suffering is also being used for for
motivational purposes but the fact that
the hedonic axis is all over the place
that that seems to be there seems to be
effect and I would add this is the case
as well in humans even though a lot of
humans don't necessarily know that
they're pursuing pleasure they're still
doing so in you know in a fairly subtle
way so it could be that the nervous
system anything with a nervous system is
pursuing pleasure yes yeah whoa cool